>>> PHASE CLAN, 2 HYPE, RDC,
EMP.
THE BIGGEST CREATORS COMPETE IN
THE ULTIMATE GAME OF DODGEBALL
FOR A $250,000 PRIZE.
SCAN QR CODE TO REP YOUR TEAM
AND WATCH THE HOH SHOWDOWN
DODGEBALL TOURNEY LIVE THIS
FRIDAY AT 8:00 EASTERN ON "HOUSE
OF HIGHLIGHTS" YOU TUBE CHANNEL.
IT'S THAT TIME.
>> IT'S TIME FOR --
♪ E.J.'S NEATO STAT OF THE
NIGHT ♪
PRESENTED BY -- NO ONE.
>> COME ON, ERNIE.
>> UNSULLIED BY SPONSORSHIP
SINCE --
>> 1989.
>> THANK YOU, DR. O'NEAL.
SO GIVEN THAT PROMO THAT WE JUST
DID FOR THE "HOUSE OF
HIGHLIGHTS" DODGEBALL, THE GUYS
UPSTAIRS THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA FOR US TO GENERATE
SOME MORE INTEREST IN IT BY I
GUESS DOING SOME TYPE OF
DODGEBALL HERE IN THE STUDIO.
I MEAN, I DON'T REALLY -- I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE RULES.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW THE RULES?
>> KIND OF.
BUT WE DO HAVE PEOPLE WE CAN
THROW AT ALSO.
>> Y'ALL DON'T HAVE DODGEBALL IN
THE SUBURBS SOME.
>> I'VE SEEN THE MOVIE
"DODGEBALL."
>> DO Y'ALL PLAY HOPS?
THE BALL HITS THE FLOOR AND HITS
YOU YOU'RE OUT?
>> NO, IT'S GOT TO HIT YOU IN
THE AIR.
>> NO HOPS.
>> AND IF I CATCH IT THEN YOU'RE
OUT.
>> UNLESS --
>> YEAH, UNLESS HE HITS ONE OF
OUR GUYS, THEN YOU'RE BACK IN.
>> Y'ALL GOT TOO MUCH TIME ON
YOUR HANDS KNOWING ALL THE
DODGEBALL RULES.
>> IT'S TWO OF US AGAINST --
>> NO, ONE HIT AND OUT.
>> NO.
I MEAN, THIS IS --
>> WE'RE NOT PLAYING?
ERNIE, YOUR MICROPHONE IS ON.
>> NOT LIKE WE'RE STAYING HERE
FOR THE REST OF THE --
>> WHY ARE YOU TAKING YOUR
JACKET OFF?
YOU'RE TRYING THROW IT HARD AT
ME?
>> WELL, IF WE'RE GOING TO THROW
THEM.
>> LET'S GO.
>> WAIT, WAIT.
>> NO, I --
>> HOLD ON.
>> LET ME TAKE MY JACKET OFF.
HIT ME WITH A BALL.
I DARE YOU.
GO AHEAD.
COME ON, ERNIE.
>> OH!
>> CHUCK'S OUT.
CHUCK, YOU'RE OUT.
>> CHUCK'S OUT FOR A MINUTE.
CHUCK, YOU'RE OUT FOR A SECOND.
>> YOU'RE OVER THE LINE!
YOU'RE OVER THE LINE, ERNIE!
>> I'VE GOT TO CATCH ONE.
>> HEY, CHUCK'S OUT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> GO AHEAD, ERNIE.
>> MY BAD.
THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
>> COME ON, CHUCK.
>> HEY, MAN, I'VE GOT A BAD
SHOULDER.
I CAN'T EVEN THROW A BALL.
>> KENNY, THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT,
KENNY.
>> NO, THEY DON'T HURT.
>> MY BAD.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
>> HE'S YOUR TEAMMATE.
>> YOU GOT OUT OF HERE SO QUICK.
>> I QUIT.
>> TWO AGAINST ONE.
>> HEY.
YOU CAN'T BEAT EL PADRI NO.
AND THE GODFATHER.
>> I GOT HIT BAD.
MAN.
>> I'M GLAD Y'ALL --
>> THERE'S ONE MAN LEFT
STANDING, CHUCK, GET HIM.
>> I CAN'T THROW.
>> OH, MY GOSH, CHUCK.
>> YOU THROW LIKE A GIRL, MAN.
>> THAT'S WHY I LOST.
LOOK WHO I'M PLAYING WITH.
Y'ALL SHOULD PUT ME WITH SHAQ,
MA